hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be going over a cool video the icelandic
gambit and it derives from the
scandinavian defense which starts with
pawn to e4 again a move from white that
you're going to see very often was just
going to give you a lot of opportunities
to actually play the icelandic gamete
and then pawn to d5 this is the
scandinavian defense after white takes
black has a lot of different options you
may have seen you know queen takes here
on d5 but this comes from knight coming
to f6 white has a lot of different
options but the Icelandic game it is the
pawn coming here to c4 and then the pawn
now coming to six now there are other
game it's the pawn could come here to c6
but the Icelandic game it again is the
pawn coming here to e6 from here there's
a lot of variations that were going to
be going over in the Icelandic gamut the
first and most common that we're going
to be spending a lot of time on is the
most is the main line and that's the
pawn coming to e6 and then the Bishop
recapturing here on e6 and again if we
kind of look at this black has given up
material for a rapid lead in developing
as two of his minor pieces developed in
the center of the board he's attacking
this you know pawn here on c4 he has
this Queen on the semi-open file the
file so you know a lot of attacking
lines white currently has none of his
minor pieces involved into the game so
he's gonna have to find a way to really
combat black strong attack so the first
thing you may see is the pawn come to d4
again he he does have the light square
bishop nf1 defending this bishop so or
this pawn here on c4 so it doesn't have
to worry about that right away he could
try to counter-attack and discern the
board with like pawn to d4 from here the
bishops just going to come to b4 put in
the King in check White has a lot of
different options one option that you
may see is just Knight coming to c3 now
this is a pretty terrible move from
white black can go ahead and bring his
Knight to e4 putting a lot of pressure
he's now attacking this night and this
Knight is pinned down how can he really
combat that he can always bring his
Queen to c2
unfortunately the Queen can now come to
d4 since the Queen was the only
protector of that pawn black is not only
taken back the material that he's lost
early on but he's now all up in White's
based it's going to be
very hard for white to figure out how to
get this light square bishop out how to
get this Night Out castle so we can get
some sort of safety because blacks
really starting to put a lot of pressure
you can always again bring this bishop
here to c4 he can always easily castle
now it's going to be very very hard for
white to hold on here blacks definitely
in the advantage right here you know why
can always try to bring his knight to f3
black and go ahead and start to exchange
him pieces he can take bishop here on c3
check so after the pawn takes the Queen
can go ahead and come to c3 after the
Queen takes the night comes on c3 as you
can tell right here not always black now
up in material not too long ago he was
down but he also has much better pawn
structure going to the end game you get
he's got to pawn structures of three
white has less pawns but he has more
pawn structures and he does have this
one isolated here on c4 which is going
to be an easy target for blacks to
really go after later on to the game so
again very very good game for black now
you may not see the Queen come to see to
another move could always be the bishop
coming here to d2 that's going to lose
automatically to the Queen coming to d4
because the queen is no longer
protecting it instead of the bishop
coming to d2 the knight could come to e2
but unfortunately this lights where
bishops no longer protecting this pawn
on c4 the bishop can now gobble up this
pawn right here again black doesn't have
a whole lot of great options now the
knight doesn't have to come to c3 early
on you could always see something like
Bishop comes to d2 but I can go ahead
and exchange here on d2 after the Queen
takes then black can play a nice little
move Queen to e7 this is a theme that
you'll see a lot in the Icelandic game
it basically setting up a discovered
attack after this Bishop moves let's say
it takes here on you know c4 there's a
discovered attack on the White King so
this is going to be a very very powerful
move from black obviously he can get his
knight involved into the game to c6 if
he wants to but at any moment he can
move this Bishop and again it's going to
be very very hard for white to get both
of these minor pieces involved into the
game so he can castle castling on the
Queen side not really
option anymore it's not going to be safe
for him so this is again is going to be
very very good for black now instead of
the bishop coming there to d2 you could
see something it'd be a lot worse but
the knight could come let's say 2 d2
from here the Queen's just going to
right away come in and gobble up this
pawn on d4 so really if you see this
first move from white just bringing his
pawn down to d4 it's very common but you
can just go ahead
hi-five your monitor or your computer
wherever you're playing chess play
Bishop to b4 know that you're just going
to run over your opponent next move you
may see and it's actually one of the
better moves from white even though it's
really painful to play white in this
position against the Icelandic gambit
but you could see Knight coming down to
f3 and then immediately the Queen is
going to come here to e7 again kind of
that tactic we talked about white has a
lot of different moves but he's not
careful the bishop is now going to just
come to c4 really attacking this light
square diagonal and again it's a
discovered attack against white and
blacks already regained all the material
now again we don't have to go in every
situation because again you're going to
do the same thing that comes to c3 and
then black is going to recapture the one
move I do want to talk about is if the
Queen comes here to e2 because again the
bishop can no longer take here it's not
a discovered attack the Queen could just
come down immediately and take the Queen
exchange so I do want to go over this
and from here the Knights just going to
come here to c6 and this is also very
powerful because blacks really getting
all these pieces you know into the game
now if you castle on the King side
that's very you know a safe defense for
your King if you cast on the Queen side
that's a much more aggressive castle so
again if black castles on the King's the
Queen side then you can see his rooks
going to be here on the D file this is a
semi-open file so this is going to be
very very good for black you know from
here White has a lot of different
options if he tried
you know his knight coming to c3 black
and going cast on the Queen side again
this rook is now very very active again
not quite as safe for the King but again
and the Icelandic gambit you're trying
to
very very aggressive this is going to be
very good also you can set the night
coming to c3 you could always see you
know pawn to d3 again kind of a weak
move blacks can do the same thing castle
on the Queen side the only move that you
may change it up a little bit is if the
pawn comes to d4 you're not really going
to cast on the Queen side anymore
because the pawn could just push down to
d5 attacking both your minor pieces this
is obviously going to be bad instead if
the pawn comes down to d4 all you're
really going to do is play Bishop here
to f5 now White has two different
options he could continue to come down
and just play you know pawn to d5 this
is probably one of the the worst moves
he can make you know from here that I
can just come to before getting ready to
attack here on c2 as long as that Queens
not there so this is going to be very
good from black you can always still
castle on the Queen side now very very
strong attack along this D file instead
of the pawn coming down to d5 the Queen
can go ahead and come here to e7 and
then black and go ahead and take here on
seat on e7 now if you look at this black
is down to materials down one pond but
all of his pieces are all of his minor
pieces are developed he can castle on
the King side he can castle on the Queen
side it's going to be very very hard for
black to white to hold on to the small
advantage that he does have
because blacks just overwhelming him as
far as the development standpoint so
this is going to be a very very good
game for black blacks actually ahead in
this position so you actually don't mind
seeing the Queen come down here to e2
earlier on in this situation it's going
to be okay so that's again what's going
to happen if the knight comes here to f3
next move you might see from white is
bringing the knight here to c3 kind of
along those you know English opening
lines it's going to be the same pretty
much from black he's going to bring his
bishop here to b4 White has a lot of
different responses we've already seen
what happens if this pawn comes here to
d4 the Knights going to go ahead and
swoop in here to e4 again we've already
kind of played this out this is going to
be very very good for black now instead
of the pawn coming here to d4 he could
always try to get his other
involvement of the game again he needs
to find a way to get safety for his King
so he could try to get his light script
Bishop involved into the game from here
black's going to go ahead and play this
you know Queen to e7 we've already
talked about the this really great
ability for the bishop to come here to
c4 so this is going to be you know again
very very good now
instead of the night coming here to f3
you could obviously a move like pawn to
a3 trying to kick the bishop away the
bishop we can go ahead and take it you
know it's not a problem if he you know
recaptures with his poem you know his
beep on then again the Queen can come
back here to e7 again putting a lot of
pressure this discovered attack right
here you know again if the Queen comes
here to e2 that's fine black can go
ahead and castle on the King side the
nican swing is rook over to e8 again
putting a lot of pressure on this efile
this is going to be very good for black
black doesn't mind at all if if instead
white decides you know let's recapture
with a C pawn you know black can go
ahead exchange off Queens and after that
the knight can come here to c6 you know
next move if he wants to he can come
over here to a5 it's going to be very
hard for white to hold on to his
material advantage obviously the next
move he could take here if the pawn
comes up he could take here on b3 again
he has a lot of different options again
his knight can come involved into the
game he can start to attack if this is
weakened he can always come here to f2
and black still has options he can
castle on the Queen side you know
putting his rook attacking on the D file
black is going to have a very very good
game in the situation so again if white
plays you know Knight to c3 early on
that is completely ok now sometimes your
opponent may not take here on e6 and
that's fine blacks still going to have a
really good game but they didn't want to
go over some of the situations that you
may see a rise from this situation right
here so first one that you may see is
Knight to c3 again symbol development
move but trying to put a lot of pressure
on this pawn to d5 y is just going to go
ahead and take after you know the pawn
takes black can go ahead and take Y can
recapture if he wants to black is going
to be ahead
as far as development he does have you
know an extra piece developed in the
center of the board and white now has
this you know he has three pawn chains
he does have this in the middle that
doesn't it's kind of isolated right
there so this is going to be okay for
black black doesn't mind that if we kind
of reverse the order instead he takes
with this Knight it's going to be
exactly the same thing black is going to
kind of come out ahead so again don't
mind this at all now if you see instead
of you know Knight to c3 if you see
Knight to f3 it's going to be very
similar if they don't want to take with
their pawn on d5 then black is going to
take the pawn on d5 so same kind of
thing you know he can capture or the
next move black can capture he can start
to develop his other minor pieces it's
going to be somewhat similar now
sometimes you may not see either the
knight you could see a move like pawn to
d4 basically saying okay you can take
this back I still want to control this
urn the board again anytime you see this
pawn coming up you're immediately
high-fiving somebody and bringing your
Bishop to b4 because you know it's going
to be a good game so from here there's a
lot of different things
you know you could always see Bishop
coming to d2 and that's fine we can go
ahead and exchange bishops let's say the
the knight retakes then blacks just
going to go ahead and retake here on d5
this is going to be a completely fine
game for black if instead of the bishop
coming there we have the knight coming
to c3 this is probably better for black
again blacks just going to recapture on
d5 and now this knight is pinned down he
can't really do anything he can't
capture this bishop he ran before so
he's kind of at a loss
you know let's say he does capture with
his pawn here on d5 black can recapture
with his Knight
he's now attacking this Knight again
also it's being pinned down he can get
his other pieces involved into the game
again this is going to be very good
black and easily castle
as soon as he wants he has King side
safety this white King is still trying
to figure out how long the heck am I
going to be safe because this entire
every scenario we're looking at the King
is kind of the middle of the board and
he's kind of attacked all the time so
again
be good for black now another thing you
may see instead of the pond coming up to
d4 a lot of people like to put their
opponents in check so you could see
Queen come down to a four very simple
blacks going to play Bishop to d7 White
has a lot of different options he really
needs to be playing Queen - you know b3
if he doesn't if he just comes back to
you know c2 or d1 those are kind of
wasted moves all blacks gonna do is just
start gobbling up material he's already
equalized right here and so it's kind of
a waste to move really doesn't have any
of his minor pieces he's not controlling
the soon the board at all anymore so
going to be a very good game from black
again the one thing that you may see is
the Queen coming back here to b3 again
adding an extra defender here on these
pawns but again you know pretty easy
from here black still going to just take
here on d5 now White has different
options he can either take with his pawn
he can always come down here and take on
b7 let's say he does come down here and
take on b7 then the knight can come to
c6 allowing the rook here to come to b8
and still protecting this pawn on a7
again it's going to be really hard for
white to kind of hold on to his queen on
b7 and let's he gets it out of the way
now if he does decide okay I want to
start getting out of the way because
black can start to attack me he did gain
this pawn and material again he took it
but from here black and play you know
Bishop to c5 he's really starting to get
all of his minor pieces involved into
the game white his Kings still in the
middle of the board he's not going to be
able to castle anytime soon this White
Queen although it did capture a pawn in
chess it's not all about being up in
material sometimes it's having more
material in the fight and right now
white does not have that so if he tried
something like Knight to f3 trying to
get something involved into the game you
know black can come here - you know g4
putting pressure on the pawn on f2 why
black just has so many different attacks
again he can cast on the King side for
safety anytime he wants to you know why
it's not really doing a whole heck of a
lot so this is going to be very good for
black in
that of you know moving his queen back
right away he could get kind of selfish
and say you know I'm just going to take
this pawn here on d5 the knight can come
here and take on d5 and then again
putting pressure on this Queen if the
Queen comes back here to you know be
three black and kind of set a trap he or
he can play you know Knight to d4 nice
little trap because you know from here
the Queen's like okay what am I going to
do ah you know I'll go ahead and take
you know this night here on d5 that's
kind of a free piece but unfortunately
again we're all about these discover two
taxes the knight can now come to c1 and
after the King moves then the bishop now
has a discovered attack so he moves
attacking the King something's going to
have to give and this queen is going to
fall very very shortly so again there's
just so many different ways for white to
hang themselves in the Icelandic gambit
those were the main lines that you'll
see in the Icelandic gambit if you guys
are curious I can make another video
instead of sometimes coming down with a
pawn to c4 you could always see
something like the pawn coming down to
d4 saying you know what I'm up a
material but I feel like something
funny's going on so I'm going to play d4
black and say you know what I'm not
going to retake you know I'm gonna play
the Portuguese gambit and let's say play
Bishop to g4 so black has a lot of
different variations but we'll save that
for another video if you guys are
interested feel free let me know but I
really enjoy the Icelandic game it again
I feel like it gives a black so many
different options and if you're playing
an opponent that's not really familiar
with it I feel like you're just going to
just run over the board because there's
so many different aggressive lines and
the entire time it's so easy to keep
your King safe either on the Keeney side
or the Queen side so feel free to let me
know what you guys think of this opening
feel free to try it out see if you guys
have success hopefully you enjoyed
watching learn something and I'll see
you guys in the next video thanks for
watching